cell phone video text messages photos
that is just
some of the evidence in a murder case
against two teens good evening to you
i'm bryan loftis and i'm denise valdez
and this is a story the i-team first
broke back in april
after the body of a las vegas man was
discovered now vanessa murphy is here
with new material at the center of this
case vanessa
brian and denise police say the parents
of sierra hal seth and aaron guerrero
told them they couldn't see each other
anymore
the teens planned on running away
together to california
and then sierra's father ended up
murdered
the i-team has reviewed dozens of photos
considered as
evidence many of them are too gruesome
to show on television but
here's what we can show you and we want
to warn you this story
is disturbing welcome back to our
youtube channel
afternoon day three after
murdering somebody whoa don't put that
on the camera
it was worth it this video is now
considered evidence in the murder case
against
16-year-old sierra halseth and
18-year-old aaron guerrero
they're accused of killing sierra's
father 45-year-old daniel halseth in
april
his body discovered inside this las
vegas home
after his mother christine halseth and
an ex-wife
realized something wasn't right they
hadn't heard from him
the i-team has obtained text messages
between sierra
and christine halseth thursday night i'm
trying to get a hold of your dad where
is he
sierra's response his phone has been
acting up it should be all fixed by
tomorrow night
no worries smiley face on friday
christine halseth is increasingly
worried about her son
why are you doing this now the police
are involved
two friends visited the house and found
a crime scene with smoke inside the home
investigators say the teens stabbed
helseth and attempted to set fire to
and dismember his body prosecutors
presented to the grand jury these photos
from before halsett's body was found
sierra purchasing bleach at winco
erin at home depot buying a saw lighter
fluid gloves and more
there's a bloody scene inside the home
with knives
saws the lighter fluid and burnt
material
police say the teens used daniel
halsey's bank cards to make purchases
and withdrawals
and put a blood-soaked rug inside the
trunk of his vehicle
which they used as a getaway car
according to detectives while they were
on the run they recorded
this cell phone video they also talk
about sex and
include a graphic detail which the
i-team has chosen not to air
the video wraps up with this exchange
so yeah
that is uncomfortable to watch sierra
halseth is charged as an adult because
according to nevada
state law anyone 16 and up accused of
murder is
automatically charged as an adult
however she cannot face the death
penalty due to her
age i reached out to her attorney and he
did not get back to me
aaron guerrero potentially can face the
death penalty since he's 18.
his attorney tells me the group which
refused whether to pursue the death
penalty at the district attorney's
office
is meeting next week about guerrero's
case and he
is preparing for that